hello everyone and welcome to a truly
remarkable game that was played in 1961
uh between two International Masters one
a Portuguese Cuban International Master
Jose Francisco Perez Perez and somewhere
it's one Perez some other places its two
Perez so I mean I I put two for good
measure hope you guys don't mind against
the Portuguese International Master
Hakeem Doral and it's it's a game that
fits right into the sorcery series I
know you guys can be the judge of it
should I put it into my sorcery uh
playlist but I I think it's um
definitely a nice one so let's check it
out like I said Jose Francisco Perez
versus Joaquin Dural he's a three to a
13 times Portuguese champion and he
represented his country in 10 chess
olympiads also he was the president of
the Portuguese Chess Federation so let's
dive straight into it uh Jose uh
Francisco Perez opens with uh upon upon
the D4 we have Knight to F6 C4 G6 Knight
to C3 and Bishop to G7 so a normal
King's Indian defense we have Ponte E4
D6 and now Bishop to G5 this is an older
continuation against the king's India
nowadays you will see some like F3 or
Knight to F3 or Bishop to E2 or even F4
uh but Bishop to G5 was what was played
as this is a game from 1961 like I've
mentioned so here after Bishop G5 we
have pawned the C5 striking against
White Center and white grabs more space
in the center with the D5 we have H6
challenging the bishop Bishop to H4 and
now Queen to A5 putting pressure on the
Knight also pinning the Knight preparing
Knight captures on e4 so Queen D2 and
pinning and now Pawn to G5 Bishop to G3
and the Knight the H5
putting pressure on the bishop but also
with some ideas of maybe placing the
bishop on E5 maybe capturing on G3 now
all depends on what white plays so here
Bishop to D3 and Knight to D7 now the
Knight can also come to E5 we have
Knight G to E2 and now Knight to E5
attacking the bishop on D3 but here
white just castles and now Knight back
to G6 uh adding more control over the F4
square and uh this position in fact has
been reached twice both times by Joaquin
Duran uh in one his opponent Torah
Alberto played A3 and that game ended in
a draw but this is the game that we are
covering and here uh Jose Francisco
Perez played Ponta F4 and it is now as
of move 13 that this game was never
repeated again so let's see how do you
react to this uh okay in the game Knight
captures and G3 was played in modern
chess a more forcing G captures and F4
would most likely happen uh for example
some like Bishop captures Knight
captures Knight captures and now Bishop
to E5 is very very annoying for white
because black doesn't care that white
can mess up black spawn structure here
because you'll Play Bishop D7 in Castle
Queen side so if anything opening up the
lines towards uh white king really help
you but in the game Knight captures and
G3 was played here we have H captors and
now Bishop to G4 uh developing the
bishop preparing the castle Queen side
Ponte E5 and now we have castles Queen
side we have A3 preparing the the
strongest moving chess and now Pawn to
H5 of course Dura wants to play H4 open
up the H file and have the Rook
controlling the H file so Rook F to B1
uh preparing that B4 push E6 look at all
this tension on the board H for coming B
for coming this is you know that it is
gonna explode somewhere so Pawn to B4
now of course the
uh black has to reacted is the queen is
under attack Queen to B6 and now Knight
the A4 attacking the queen and putting
more pressure on that C5 Pawn so Queen
to A6 basically the only uh Square for
the queen and now comes Knight eat the
C3 uh interestingly White's uh B
captures on C5 would be a lot better
because there's just uh no no good way
to reply for black here especially if
you capture tonight if you capture the
Knight just T captures on D6 and black
resigns this is a completely unplayable
even if you trade down some material it
still doesn't matter there's nothing for
you to play to give you a fun line let's
say if he captures on the five Bishop to
F5 check and now if King B8 you can even
sacrifice The Rook if King captures Rook
to B1 check King the A8 and not the
spectacular Bishop to E4 I mean the
black's position just falls apart there
is no defense against Bishop captures on
the five Checkmate and even if you
capture the bishop Queen captors will
again be Checkmate so I mean terrible
stuff here uh it's not a fourth line but
uh I mean the night hanging here isn't
really hanging so instead and we have
Knight eat the C3 that's why it denied
um well it was okay not to defend it D
captures on E5 now we have B captures
and C5 opening up the B file now and the
E captures an F4 and now we have Pawn to
C6 it's a it's a race will black be
first open up the H file or will white
get the attack happening on the queen
side uh and here Bishop to D4 check is
very strong for uh for Duran but he goes
for B captures and C6 he's not afraid to
open up lines uh but now comes spawn to
C5 an attack is opened up towards his
queen queen to A5 and now Queen to B2 uh
threatening uh Quinta Quinta uh B7
Checkmate and here Bishop to D4 check
and now King the F1 interestingly uh
King the H1 although uh you don't want
to put the the King on the same file as
The Rook uh you don't really care
there's no time for H4 because Checkmate
is hanging and it's very very hard to
defend against this so King the F1 was
played this gives the black a few more
ideas because now black has the Escape
King the D7 and okay it doesn't seem
like you can survive this I mean look at
all the pawns the bishop denied the
queen coming to B7 so Queen B7 check
King to E8 and now Queen captures and C6
with check a bit more forcing with
Bishop captures on G6 with this white
retains the winning Advantage but okay
this is 1961 we don't use such fancy
turns here here we say uh okay that's
that's a nice one so Queen captures on
C6 check King to f8 and now Rook the B5
and look at this the black queen is
trapped there is nothing black can do
and the black should just resign however
we would not be showing this game if
this happened maybe we would but not not
under these circumstances here Knight
the E5 now okay you capture my queen I'm
gonna capture your queen on C6 and here
we have Queen to B7 actually capturing
the black queen is the best thing you
can do here and then the game trains
down into some sort of a weird game
after decal present C6 where black
continues the attack on the king side
white has a past C Pawn so all in all
it's a draw but a very very complicated
draw so instead after Knight to the E5
we have Queen the B7 here now the black
one is still hanging uh again should
black just resign well not really
because now black is completely winning
but you guys will have to figure it out
how ahua Kim durao did it so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the winning idea for black while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that
okay there's nothing we can do about the
queen but there is something we can do
obviously I mean I'm not just asking you
to pause the video for no reason and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Ponte H4 that's the good
stuff and now you see the Bishops are
slicing this way the Knight is
controlling F3 the punk can capture on
G3 can be pushed to F3 The Rook will be
controlling the H file so can white
defend this and is there something white
can play other than capturing the queen
well there really isn't a good move here
there's no way to threaten the black
king the blacking is a remarkably safe
and f8 so here uh Queen captures an F5
uh an A5
grabbing grabbing material now age
captures on G3 threatening Rook to H1
Checkmate as the Bishops are slicing all
the way here so of course white has to
move King to E1 and now uh if you're
locking the two with the white king will
escape so Bishop to E3 is still
controlling all of the squares here and
threatening Rook to H1 but now it's a
bit different because the bishop now can
go back to the F1 Square which is what
he does Bishop F1 Rook the H1 by Dura
and now we have Queen to B5 adding more
Defenders to the bishop here so if you
have to give back a little bit of
material doesn't really matter but now
comes Ponte F3 the absolute strongest
move here if you allow captures here
then it's it's all over the bishop is
pinned uh the problem is there's no way
to stop this G captures an F3 and now
Pawn to G2 uh again how do you how do
you play this uh we have F captures on
G4 at least eliminating one of the
attackers the bishop and G4 and now G1
Queen now the queen is back in the game
and now how do you defend well Rook to
A2 you have to stop Queen to have to
check so here we have Queen to G3 check
yeah interestingly and sadly here Duram
misses a beautiful Mitten seven uh that
starts with Knight to F3 check it's hard
to uh fine because after night F3
checking the one you have to go back
with the Knight and everyone knows that
the hardest move to find is with the
Knight back so here are Knights the D5
at night to D4 and the white resigns you
don't even care that the White Queen is
hanging basically you only care about
these two squares being covered by the
Knight and the bishop covering this
square and now whatever you play with Y
doesn't really matter just Queen
captures and F1 will be Checkmate
there's nothing you can do of course uh
the black one will be captured but the
Rook will deliver Checkmate so the game
did not end here but that's also good
for us because more action to be had so
Queen to G3 check came to D1 now Queen
to F3 check King to C2 and now Rook
captures on F1 grabbing that Bishop D6
now white hopes to get some sort of an
attack against the black king but now
Knight to C6 stopping everything the
queen nicely defends the Knight King to
beat you and now Rook the F2 with check
and King the A1 so did the white finally
uh find some sort of a safe haven
against the black's attack uh not really
Queen H1 check look at this Knight's the
B1 and now Bishop to D4 check and Knight
the B2 look at these Knights here I mean
incredible this Knight is pinned by the
queen here this Knight is pinned by the
bishop uh there is nothing you can do
and how do you how do you break through
here uh well that is up to you to figure
out uh feel free to pause the video and
try to find a forced mating 5 while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on on spotting This
Modern mate uh here whenever you're you
know Finding Checkmate you have to
imagine pieces where they are not
imagined if this Knight was here this
would be a smothered mate so how do we
get the Knight there congratulations to
everyone who founded Knight the B4 and
now you're just threatening Knights to
see too because the knights cannot move
and there's really no way to stop this
there's no way for the queen to stop the
the Knight getting there so what you do
you accept the Knight eight captures on
B4 but now why did we give up the night
what's what's the idea well now the
queen no longer guards the Knight on B2
uh and now Queen to C1 and now both the
Queen Bishop and Rook are attacking the
Knight on B2 and there's no way uh to
add another Defender it's just a sad sad
way for white to just wait for the end
of the game real characters on A7 Bishop
captures on B2 check Rook cap press on
B2 only move and now Queen captures on
B2 so really a spectacular regular queen
sacrifice born not out of maybe some
sort of a some sort of a brilliant
planning ideas strategy or something but
out of necessity as uh well here you
just did not have anything or maybe he
got his Queen trapped there for a reason
maybe he put the queen there said oh I
uh I mean I'm gonna play H4 I'm gonna
play for for checkmate whatever happens
even if I have to give up the queen at
least my opponent will spend a temper to
going after the queen so truly a
remarkable game I I think it might be
fitting for the sorcery series but like
I said you guys are welcome to comment
on that so brilliant game by yeah and
like I said this was played in 1961 and
I will show you the end of the game as
uh Joachim Dural faced the Bobby Fischer
uh six years after this game was played
and this was the position he again had
the black pieces and Fisher had the
white here and it was in the uh in the
Havana Olympiad in 1966 and Bobby has
the winning position here but it's very
interesting how Bobby does it so just as
an extra to this video feel free to
pause the video here and win the game
for Bobby Fischer uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on always paying
attention to that move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Pawn to B4 this is what Bobby played
and it was in this position that his
opponent resigned the game in this case
uh Hakim Duran as there is nothing more
to be done here or maybe they played a
few more moves I don't know but it'd be
cooler if he resigned here so let's just
say he did although he probably didn't
because uh well Bobby now created a
mating net and there is no way out of
this for the black king so he didn't
play the end game to promote a pawn he
just uh completely uh immobilized the
black king the problem is you have the
E4 square but if you go for E4 just root
captures and see for checking the five
and King D3 and next move you are
getting checkmated there's no no
avoiding this and if you try something
else like C characters on B3 I'll pass
on uh doesn't matter that's exactly what
Bobby wanted now the D3 square has been
vacated for the white king So King D3
and again there's no there's no stopping
a C4 check the only way to stop C4 check
is the Capron A4 but then okay you still
play it and then black has to give up
the rook and that's it so basically by
playing Pawn to B4 uh black has to
choose uh between Checkmate uh and uh
well just severe material loss uh so
yeah that's the game or rather those
were the games hope you guys enjoyed it
very nicely played by uh Doral on both
accounts here by just winning a
brilliant game uh in the coming back
from uh from a seemingly lost position
uh many times and also on on act
reaching an end game against Bobby
Fischer that's I mean that's uh some
would considered that a victory in
itself so I once again really hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
Kerrigan David Masa and Matthew Benoit
Revolution reptiles YouTube and Michael
Colbert for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day